he won't survive for long out there
there's room for you in our group if you
want
she's just another mouth to feed
if we leave her out here she'll die
I don't mean to question your sense of
Mercy David
maybe that's God's will
let me protect you
the others want to kill you
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
will be my last of us episode 8 trailer
video there's a whole bunch of Easter
eggs and references so we'll break it
all down if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the episodes and careful for spoilers
from episode 7 if you haven't seen it
yet the title of the episode is when we
are in need which is a reference to
Ellie's fight with David's group here
David's the main antagonist here in the
prayer that they have written on their
Banner when we are in need he shall
provide like their group treats Ellie as
if she's sent by God to answer their
prayers for food because there's this
whole bad vibe to the trailer and that's
on purpose David's group are
affectionately referred to by the fans
as the cannibals and there's a huge Troy
Baker Cameo here he's playing James and
secondary antagonist part of David's
group and even though it seems like he's
the bad guy he wants to kill Ellie like
he pulls his gun up on her a couple
times you find out that he's actually
one of the more merciful ones of the
bunch it seems like we're gonna get a
much bigger flashback on their group to
show how they became what they are in
present day some of these scenes might
be happening in present day though but
they're meant to be a group of minor
antagonists for Ellie and Joel later in
the events of the first game and they're
meant to be part of the same group that
they ran into at the university the same
one that Joel killed he was from David's
group remember they haven't traveled
very far she just drug him to a house
nearby so they're still in that area
around the university when she runs into
David's group here this is all right out
of the game with a bunch of stuff added
in like they've done with previous
episodes before like you get more
backstory on all the characters just to
flesh everyone out
hello
we just want to talk any sudden moves
and I put one right between your eyes
ditto for Buddy Boy over there
what do you want
name's David
this here's my friend James
from a larger group
women children
they're all very very hungry
so am I
women and children all very hungry too
well huh
maybe we could
trade you for some of that meat there
what do you need
weapons
ammo clothes medicine
in a lot of the episodes La by herself
trying to deal with this other group
while she still continues to nurse Joel
back to hell like at the beginning of
the trailer you see the aftermath of
episode 6 where she slowly nurses him
back to Consciousness she managed to
find some string and close his wound but
he's still on the edge of death like
he's still barely there you see her
hunting for the Stag to try and find
them some food showing off some of the
skills that she's learned some survival
skills she's not completely there yet
but she's gotten better at surviving on
her own this is all right out of the
games
so in the game this is basically when
she runs into David's group like she
runs into David and James like oh hey
there surprise surprise looking for some
food are you in the vibe you get from
David and James in the trailer is very
similar to the vibe in the games where
they present themselves as very
benevolent people like oh hey it's
another mouth to feed so great why don't
we help each other when really they have
much more Sinister plans for her and
suddenly you realize the scene of them
looking with the banner above them in
this meeting room here in this Lodge
when we are in need he shall provide is
them treating Ellie like she's a nice
snack sent by God because it's winter
and they've run out of food
and like I said you they're treating the
Troy Baker character like he's one of
the worst ones trying to kill Ellie he's
actually meant to be the nicer of the
two of them of him and David because he
wants to do this quickly James tells
David that she's another mouth to feed
they can't even think of keeping her
around maybe God wants her to die maybe
that's his will it's just not feasible
keeping another person around but David
argues with him that they should like
he's trying to make it seem like he's
trying to help this person and here's
where the other shoe drops because in
the games around this time there are
infected in this area but remember Joel
said a long time ago that the biggest
thing they had to worry about in these
remote areas were other people the whole
idea is that other people are even more
dangerous than the fungus there are
infected in this area where they are
because it's somewhat popular there's a
small group of people like David's group
is a small group of people so it's not
like it's completely free of the fungus
but it's not nearly as bad as it is in
the quarantine Zone in more populated
areas that's where you tend to find more
of the fungus just because it feeds on
other people that's its food source
basically and just like Joel told her
now we can't have a fire because the
people out there are Raiders that look
to kill us and do even worse things to
us and the even worse part is where we
get to David's group in the trailers it
seems like David tries to help her like
oh he's the nice guy like he's trying to
protect her nope he basically wants to
trap Ellie and keep her as his own
personal play thing in the most sadistic
way so now all the other members of his
group that might want to eat her which
is bad enough on its own somehow seem
like the better option of the two Troy
Baker not coming off as bad in these
trailers just kill her and be done with
it don't play with your food there's
lots of moments when the games in this
trailer are just a few changes they've
expanded the scene with Dave's group
just to flesh out their characters their
group's backstory a little more her
hunting the deer at the beginning here
is right out of the games but in the
episode she's using Joel's rifle instead
of the bow thrown the games as you can
see that's basically how she winds up
running into David's group and they
slowly begin to find out like David
starts to figure out who she is wait a
minute
slaughtered
oh yeah crazy man
[Music]
and get this he's crazy man traveling
a little girl
there were a couple of our people that
came running back and said they ran into
a crazy old man and a little girl that
was with him and some of them died so
it's a very suspenseful episode like a
very crazy episode compared to last week
if you didn't think there was enough
action in episode 7 this is completely
the opposite of that it's like
wall-to-wall action it starts out with
Ellie trying to save Joel hunting this
deer like big test for her in survival
skills and then running into Davis Group
and trying to deal with them on her own
mind you later in the trailer you see
the lodge where they were meeting on
fire that seems like Ellie trying to
make her escape and Joel basically has
to force himself to stay conscious long
enough to try and save her in his
condition after she's been captured by
David so it does wind up being a big
rally for Joel's character too the way
they played this though they kind of
done this in previous episodes as well
where they moved through the plot really
fast because in the games it was a much
bigger time Jump between when Joel was
wounded at the University by David's
group and when La first encounters David
in the wild here with James and remember
there's only one more episode after this
and they're supposed to cover the entire
first game during season one which is
why they're moving through the plot so
fast kind of feels like they needed 10
episodes instead of just nine so that
means that the finale is gonna have to
be super sized because there's still so
much stuff that happens during the first
game we can wait to talk about that
until they drop the trailer for episode
nine remember episode 9 is the finale
they're still on the mission to find the
fireflies this has just been a detour to
nurse Joel back to hell so he doesn't
die on her but they decided to try and
make it to Salt Lake City Utah where the
fireflies had indicated that they'd
retreated to on that map which is still
a pretty solid Journey from them they
haven't gone that far remember Ellie
just drugged him to a nearby house in
this suburb near the university it
wasn't that far so they're still in the
nearby area where they were in episode
six that's why you see David's group
patrolling in and around these same
houses where Ellie has been hiding with
Joel it seems like they're trying to
stay in the trailer that David is like
the pastor of their group which is adds
to its level of sinister and evil to his
character oh the holy man he wouldn't be
the evil person he wants to protect this
young child not keep her like a pet
I'll be an evil man and this scene of
David talking to her saying the others
want to kill you I want to keep you
alive is him talking to her after he's
trapped her Behind These Bars also right
out of the games they might have changed
the dialogue just a little bit they did
that with Riley's conversation at the
end of episode 7 but it's the same basic
scene just like the scenes in episode 7
and previous episodes overall the
episodes have adapted the plot of the
games pretty closely like a lot of the
scenes in the dialogue are taken
directly from the games they've just
expanded on some of that like episode
three is a good example where they just
add a whole bunch of backstory for
characters that you only get a little
bit from in the games for those of you
asking about season 2 and Beyond they've
actually said that they're planning on
splitting the events of the second game
for future season so like season two
won't be all of the second game it'll be
like the first half of the second game
maybe even less than that if you haven't
played the games the second game is
almost like twice as long as the first
game there's just so much more stuff
going on in that and this is also
assuming they eventually make the last
of us three game which Neil druckman has
talked about in the past is there a lot
of was part three I'll just say right
now our focus is on we have we have the
multiplayer game coming out and we're
going to reveal more of that later this
year beyond that
um it's the same process we've always
had uh we don't
um
we don't do something that we're not
extremely passionate about so unless we
had a really good compelling story to
keep the story going
then we it ends in part two the way he
talks about is very non-committal like
well if we find a good story we'll do it
but clearly they probably plan on doing
it just because the first two games were
so successful even though fans weren't
quite as hot on the second game mostly
stuff like that comes down to money and
they're supposedly making The Last of Us
multiplayer game right now and that's
going to be extra material that wasn't
featured in the first two games like
it'll be new story with other characters
we'll see if they incorporate any of
that stuff into future Seasons as well
but if you spotted any other Easter eggs
or references in the trailer that I
didn't talk about in the video just
write down below in the comments in my
full episode 8 video will post next
Sunday after they release it the other
real big reminder is that the
Mandalorian season 3 episodes are
starting and I'm doing videos for all
the episodes just like I did for
previous Seasons more Pedro Pascal Pedro
Pascal into the Pascal verse those
episodes release at midnight Tuesday
nights Pacific time my episode videos
will post later in the mornings on
Wednesdays they just released the
opening scene from the Mandalorian
season three episode one you can click
here for my video from that and click
here for my full Last of Us episode 7
video in Easter eggs
foreign
[Music]